[Musique]
OK et puis on revient sur l'inverse
d'hier ok avec beaucoup de relâchement
ici en laissant sur un cours de tennis
Yoann est imperturbable
joueur de tennis fauteuil depuis plus de
15 ans il est classé parmi les 10
meilleurs joueurs français avec 5
entraînements par semaine ils souhaitent
maintenant se qualifier pour les JO de
Paris 2024
[Musique]
pour moi Johan c'est un mec comme un
autre c'est en termes de tennis c'est
exactement la même chose je ne change
rien sur mon approche c'est un joueur
pro je l'entraîne comme un pro il est en
fauteuil mais pour moi ça c'est comme
s'il était en fauteuil
l'idée c'est vraiment de le pousser dans
certains chemins d'aller chercher très
loin
sur le bord du terrain Julien un ami de
longue date est admiratif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amputé fémorale à 18 ans à la suite d'un
cancer des eaux Johan s'est reconstruit
grâce au sport et à son activité
professionnelle un parcours que son ami
Julien suit de près depuis plus de 20
ans nous avoue que je suis un fan de
tennis et le fait qu'il soit champion
handisport de tennis et quelque chose
qui me touche beaucoup et c'est vrai que
pouvoir le suivre au quotidien dans son
projet sportif c'est quelque chose de
très agréable c'est courageux de parce
qu'il a vécu et il y a une vraie force
de caractère et de la résilience et il a
fait de son handicap une force et en
tout cas titre personnel pour moi c'est
un exemple c'est un modèle parce que
parfois on se fait du souci pour des
petits tracas du quotidien et quand on
voit ce qu'il a traversé et comment ils
sont des sorties on peut on ne peut que
tirer le chapeau
[Musique]
le regard des autres un sujet qui touche
beaucoup de personnes en situation de
handicap Yoann a su le dépasser au fur
et à mesure du temps ça va faire
maintenant 20 ans que j'ai perdu ma
jambe effectivement le début a été
difficile la plus faire un deuil j'étais
adolescent jeune adulte donc
effectivement le regard des gens à cette
période-là était beaucoup plus
compliquée pour moi que maintenant quand
je me fais accompagner de certaines
personnes ces gens-là voient le regard
des autres mais moi je le vois plus du
tout alors au tout départ je ne
connaissais pas il y a eu le côté
curiosité beaucoup de questions etc donc
c'est pas évident parce que on peut
mettre mal à l'aise la personne et en
apprenant à le connaître en fait c'est
devenu naturel entre guillemets je peux
je ne fais même plus attention à son
handicap il y a quelques années nous
étions aller au restaurant ensemble et
en sortant j'ai vu les regards se porter
sur nous
et donc j'ai demandé naïvement à Yoann
Yohan tout le monde nous regarde
pourquoi tout le monde nous regarde et
en fait j'avais même oublié son handicap
et il me dit mais Julien c'est parce que
j'ai ma prothèse en fait il y a des
personnes qui vont vraiment aller à la
rencontre de la de la de la personne en
situation de handicap
l'accompagner lui dire que voilà vous
êtes une personne formidable vous faites
des vraiment des choses extraordinaires
dans votre vie et d'autres personnes qui
justement ont peut-être jugé avant de
connaître la personne et vont se terrer
un petit peu et moi peut-être dans du
négatif mais ça c'est un corps voilà je
pense qu'un corps des efforts à faire
pour justement
laisser place va diversité quel qu'il
soit
[Musique]
dépasser son handicap et viser toujours
plus haut un objectif que Johan se
promet de poursuivre au moins jusqu'en
2024 un défi courageux que Julien compte
bien partager à ses côtés